hi there Matt here I'm excited to share
ways you can continue to hone and
develop your communication skills that
start here on think fast talk smart the
podcast
visit faster smarter.io where you'll
find free quick tip videos our monthly
newsletters with the latest edition
coming out at the end of July and
information about my new book beyond
faster smarter.io you can find
transcripts of all of our episodes by
going to
gsb.stanford.edu and search think fast
talk smart enjoy these resources and now
enjoy your think fast talk smart the
podcast episode
hi Matt here I've recently found myself
at home and at work in some pretty
interesting coaching situations
and I remembered a conversation I had on
this podcast with my friend and
colleague Collins Dobbs where he gave
really practical and tactical advice for
giving constructive feedback as a coach
and as a mentor
I really liked his notion of connect
then Coach as well as the idea of pace
space and Grace enjoy this conversation
from our archive
one thing all managers parents and
romantic Partners know is that things
don't always go the way we want them to
which means we sometimes have to have
challenging conversations with our
employees our children and our partners
well never fun these tough talks can be
made easier and more effective
hello I'm Matt Abrahams and I teach
strategic communication at Stanford
Graduate School of Business welcome to
think fast talk smart the podcast
I am super excited to chat with Collins
Dobbs Collins is a lecture in management
and an executive coach at Stanford
Graduate School of Business he teaches
in several MBA courses including
interpersonal Dynamics and Leadership
Labs among many things Collins focuses
on diverse leadership styles and
cultures and how they impact
interpersonal relationships and
management Effectiveness welcome Collins
thank you for being here I am so looking
forward to chatting with you thank you
Matt thank you for inviting me I look
forward to our conversation excellent
let's go ahead and get started now when
most of us are confronted with a
challenging conversation we we focus
almost exclusively on how we want the
other person to change might focusing on
other things be more helpful to us
I I think it can Matt certainly as a
starter I'll tell you one of the things
that I like to think about is
I think it's very helpful to slow
ourselves down and to focus on our own
awareness of what's going on for us and
part of that is is am I aware of the
depth of my excitement the depth of my
resistance the depth of my emotions and
clearly you know what is it that I want
from this particular conversation myself
and do I feel grounded to have that
conversation so I think that's a great
place to start the other thing uh Matt
that I find that's helpful is is if I
can slow myself down and be anchored I
am going to be a better listener because
now I kind of have cleared some space
and some anxiety away so I can do that
and then the corollary is and then it
also allows me to then listen more
actively or more openly and rather than
necessarily listening for how do I cause
change in the other person necessarily
can I start with some curiosity and
certainly with the goal of mutual
understanding so I think that's usually
a nice Baseline to start with yeah so so
important many of us myself included
when I'm in these situations I'm so
focused on what I want the other person
to do or how I want them to change and
what I'm hearing you say is we have to
pause I love this notion of slowing down
because our minds are often so active
slow down really reflect on what's
motivating our position focus on where
we're at and I love what you said about
focusing on what our goal is sometimes I
know for myself I just want change and I
don't think deeply enough about what's a
reasonable goal for that change and then
you you spoke the magic word listening I
think in all of these situations we
could benefit by listening and anything
that gets us into a place where we can
listen better will be so helpful so
thank you for that guidance really
really important do you have suggestions
for ways for structure during
constructive or critical feedback one
model that I've used um in in the
Executive Education we use a piece of it
in interpersonal Dynamics it's kind of a
three-step and the three considerations
right and the first one is it's called
the air feedback model so the a stands
for action and in some ways the way I
like to talk about that is very simply
can we share data that is accessible to
both parties involved in the
communication so as for Action so if I
can name a specific action that you took
something you said something you did
something that is there and obvious that
we can refer to as a concrete data point
for us to kind of both look at so this
the specificity it helps with the
conversation the I is so given that
action what was the impact on me right
what was the impact and so very often
what happens is is we're respond based
on actions the other person is actually
responding
not necessarily to your intentions but
often they're responding to what was the
impact of the of that behavior so when
you're getting feedback you might say so
in the meeting during the presentation I
was about to review the numbers and it
was at that point that you jumped in and
said hey you know wait a minute before
we do that I think there's an
opportunity to talk a little bit more
about the marketing plan
so the action was when you joined in at
that moment the impact on me at that
moment was I felt frustrated I felt
confused because I wasn't ready to go
there and I think I was building the
narrative that we agreed on that's the
kind of that might share that with the
colleague to say that was the action
that was the impact on me and then the r
for air is a request and so now that
I've shared that the request might be so
in future meetings what I would find
very helpful would be
either a if you can hold that comment or
if you could check in with me and say so
Collins I know you're finishing the you
know your portion of the presentation
when you're ready I would like to maybe
Circle back and transition to cover
another part how does that work with you
so that's a specific request so then you
give the other person some Hooks and
handles for how they can actually
provide feedback for you that is less
risky or certainly that in a way that
you might feel that's more responsive
wow I really like that Air Model the the
idea that you identify an action that
it's observable it's objective that you
can see you identify the impact that it
had on you as the recipient of that
action and then you make a request and I
like the acronym it helps you clear the
air you know when I teach this the
feedback skills I I love that you have a
model that we can follow I look at
feedback as really an invitation to
problem solve to to try to figure out a
way to work together and I love that
this structure ends with the request
it's it's your request which could be as
you gave an example a declaration here's
what I need from you or it could be a a
question it could be an inquiry how can
we collaborate together so I think if
all of us were to embrace this Air Model
we could make our feedback more concise
and more clear and what I really like is
it also strips out some of the emotion
which leads to my next question about
what thoughts and advice do you have on
how to manage the emotions that we often
feel when we find ourselves thinking
about and actually in challenging
communication situations when you find
yourself in a situation let's say I'm
going about to receive feedback from
from you as a colleague one of the
things that's really anchoring is I
might say a version of so Matt I'm
looking forward to hearing what you have
to say really value
um you know your thoughts I must say at
this moment I'm feeling a range of
emotions which could be I'm both
naturally have some anxiety because I
don't know what you might say I might I
may have disappointed you in a way that
I'm not aware of and that doesn't feel
good and I'm also pretty curious because
you know in the past you've really given
me helpful feedback so I've got a mix of
emotions I just want you to know that so
that we know kind of what's what's in
the room so there's a way in which
rather than in some ways totally
stripping away emotion and trying to
make the feedback fully cognitive what
usually is more resonant and connecting
is is can we then connect at that place
because then you might say you have more
information you might say oh violence I
didn't know that we work together a lot
to me I wasn't you know I had no idea
that this might be higher Stakes for you
and it gives you more choices in terms
of you know how you you know might
deliver the message or how we might then
talk about what's going on because very
often what can happen is is we believe
that we're delivering the message full
content full details and being quite
helpful to another person and the person
walks away not taking it in certainly in
the way that we had hoped and sometimes
that's because there was so much
unexpressed emotion in the room they
weren't fully prepared to hear it in a
way and so if and then you walk away
believing that they did and then it can
lead to again further sort of missed
expectations further down the line so
that's that's one of the things that we
like to think about in terms of like can
we just honor and make a part of our
experience and I might say to you just
like you said you know on the request
side it would also be helpful Matt for
me to hear how are you like what's going
on for you in terms of this are you
feeling any of this you know similar
emotions different emotions so starting
from this place of I like to say very
often connection before coaching is
really powerful right because very often
our best coaching happens sometimes and
we for forgot to actually connect
emotionally with the other person and
they can easily miss it and as you know
this happens in our professional
relationships and it often happens in
our our dear personal relationships as
well well first and foremost Collins uh
I would never give you negative feedback
about the information you share you give
wonderful advice and guidance and thank
you for clarifying the role that emotion
plays and and I have to agree that that
naming emotions owning emotions and then
it sounds like soliciting input on
others emotions can really help in this
notion of connecting before coaching is
really powerful because a lot of us want
to jump right to that coaching piece
here's what you need to do to be better
or different or to help me or to help
yourself but making that connection on
an emotional level sounds like is
absolutely critical to have lasting
impact
I'm curious uh you you triggered a
question in my mind are there things we
can do when we are receiving feedback to
help us be more open to it I know
personally that there are times where I
will get very defensive especially if I
know potential critical feedback is
coming are there things that you teach
or perhaps you do in your own life to
help you be more receptive when you're
receiving constructive feedback
I tell you one of the things that I've
noticed when often feedback gets spoken
about is it there's often a lot more
focus on the process and the skill set
in delivering emotions
versus receiving emotions and I actually
believe that the The Leverage of a
strong feedback conversation actually
sits with the receiver by and large
right and so what I love about your
question is is one of the things that I
then try to do is adopt that mindset
first because right if I think that on
the receiving side I just kind of am
without agency I feel naturally to your
point most people can often then feel
quite defensive and I'm just sort of
Less open but if I can adopt a mindset
on the receiving side that you know what
I have some agency about this is data I
I will kind of hear it from a place of
curiosity and interest and I have some
choices about what I do with that which
could be a range of a right now that
might feel a little bit too much for me
to deal with but I appreciate it and
will study that a little more and follow
up with you later as I kind of get
grounded with that or B I might say
that's a great idea I hadn't thought
about that can you help me unpack that a
little more in terms of impact on you or
other examples so I can actually learn
something about it or you know or I
might do something totally you know
different with it but if I then as the
receiver can put myself in a place of
curiosity a place of agency and a place
of like kind of openness to this can as
you were talking about feedback being
learning and problem solving it opens up
a whole new world of possibilities wow
the the the power of having the right
approach and mindset can certainly make
a difference and I love that that notion
of curiosity and interest in what the
person is saying uh We've we've done a
lot of talking on this podcast about
seeing opportunities and offers in other
people's uh actions relative to us and
and the feedback is an offer it's an
offer to help us be better to help us
grow perhaps change in a direction we
hadn't thought of but you have to have
the right mindset and the notion of
agency strikes me as being so important
I often think of when I talk to my kids
that I want to when giving them feedback
give them a sense that they have some
control in the situation and it sounds
like that agency goes beyond the
parenting relationship but can be
involved in lots of other relationships
as well one of the things I appreciate
so much about the work you do Collins is
not only is is the advice just very
actionable it's really memorable too I
like the air model it's easy to remember
the acronym I like the connect before
coaching I have heard you also talk
about pace space Grace can you define
what you mean by this and and how can we
benefit by deploying these Concepts
love that thank you Matt
played I played basketball in college
and one of the things that we talked a
lot about was you know when you're
thinking about a game plan depending on
how you're playing against you know
pacing and spacing right on the floor
and all of that so those two concepts
have sort of been in my mindset as I
think about organizations as I think
about game plans as I think about
strategies and one of the things that
has sort of emerged for me you know more
recently is
it comes up so much in Communications
and Leadership Effectiveness which is
we're living at such a pace of 2021
which is usually super fast in the
pandemic it can feel quite distance but
still fast with zoom and we're like
we're trying to take in so many data so
much data from so many different sources
that the page just feels really
generally rushed and even prepending um
it was the same way so sometimes the
myths or the opportunities as a coach
very often is I try to slow it down and
take a look at you know the themes
what's coming up how do we explore
emotions what are our hopes what are our
desires what are the patterns that we're
recognizing ourselves and others can we
slow down long enough to unpack sort of
more of what's there which leads a
little bit to the space so what what
often happens I notice in um
relationships or from coaching is is
over time you know we worked together
we're College we begin to have a
shorthand or you know shorter
expectations and what sometimes can
happen or people in our life which
sometimes can happen is is we start to
actually narrow the possibilities not
even knowing it we start to narrow the
possibilities of you know what the other
person's actions might be or our actions
might be and so sometimes what I like to
say is is okay we feel like we're at a
stuck place can we pull back and create
some space for other potential
opportunities where else might this go
what else have we not considered how
might this be different than what we had
hoped so there's something about that's
freeing I think for us individually and
often the people we're working with when
we can kind of pull back and slow down
and just notice breathe differently
pacing notice that there may be other
interesting possibilities that we hadn't
considered and very often Solutions can
come from the additional space that we
create with each other and
saying that there is often a lot of
concern about I'm not exactly sure I
know the right thing to say in this
difficult conversation right so I have a
choice there so I might either then
withhold and just say it's just not
worth saying it and usually what happens
is if we start to develop that pattern
so much goes unsaid over time that the
behaviors that we start we start to
interact with each other from a pretty
distorted reality in terms of what's
really there so so part of what I like
to think about is this can we contract
with speak with each other directly
about you know what there's gonna there
will be times in which I will do some
things I didn't say I might do some
things I will do some things that might
disappoint you or that might leave you
uh dissatisfied and so will you right in
a relationship over time can we agree
that in those moments we will step back
and we will allow ourselves a little a
little Grace right we will allow
ourselves to say you know we're not
perfect and we are trying and we will
make space with each other to do a
deeper dive well to refer back to your
basketball career in college what a slam
dunk of good advice there uh this notion
of slowing things down so you can see
the situation as it is giving yourself a
wider view of the decision space that
you're in so you can see other potential
Solutions or options and this notion of
I like how you phrased it Contracting
with others to to have an agreement that
we're going to give each other a little
Grace a little bit of acceptance can
certainly help in in Myriad situations
not just in challenging situations but
lots of other situations so I really
appreciate that advice before we end I'd
like to ask you the same three questions
I ask everyone who joins me are you up
for that Collins I yeah excellent then
here's our first question if you were to
capture the best communication advice
you ever received as a five to seven
word presentation slide title what would
it be
who communication is a team sport oh I
love it from a basketball player even
help me understand uh how it's a team
sport
think about my role my responsibility
the things that matter to me and I have
to think about
my teammates right role responsibilities
and I have to think about how we perform
based upon challenges ahead of ourselves
so there's something that I like that I
guess what gravity about that is it
reminds me that this is a we're in this
together and I have to be more expansive
and not just go internal and become
defensive or only see my my view of the
world that analogy is so powerful it
brings up so many things you have to
coordinate you have to work together you
have to collaborate so many things so I
I love that and and it came in at five
words instead of seven which is also
exciting
Collins who is it a communicator that
you admire and why
I would say Martin Luther King what I
what I'm drawn to in Martin Luther King
it was a combination of certain
certainly competence right it was the it
was the connection of the voice it was
the connection of the rhythm of it it
was the and in addition to to that map
there was always sort of these many
bigger subtle messages that were very
provocative and I thought I also think
in many cases they were also very
collaborative I often left with thinking
about what else about this did I not
hear and so he would be the one
Communicator that I go back and listen
to over and over again and I will learn
something new and different wow well it
was such a tribute to Dr Martin Luther
King Jr who was a phenomenal
communicator and did so by blending so
many different techniques and thorough
understanding of how to create a story
that's compelling and as you said a true
Testament of a good communicator is the
desire to to hear more from the person
and go back and reflect on what they
said so thank you for sharing the final
question what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe knowing the
audience
and believing
That We're In It Together
you need to to know yourself and
understand where you're coming from you
have to take the time to understand and
appreciate your audience and then really
take that extra step that it's a
collaborative Endeavor communication is
a collaborative Endeavor and as we
mentioned earlier it's not always
Pleasant there are times where you have
to have challenging conversations but by
leveraging the tools that you so
graciously shared with us today about
how to structure feedback how to take a
sense of agency when receiving feedback
about how to look at communication as a
coordinated effort has been so helpful
Collins I thank you so much your advice
and feedback resonate very loudly for me
and I hope for our listeners thank you
for your time Matt thank you for
inviting me and thank you for the
wonderful work that you do
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast
produced by Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business for more
information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
stanford.gsp